so I've roughly gone from negative PI
and 5 PI ish now it's just for the sake
of drawing not for the sake of solving
so you can see the negative PI in a
Firefly the actual width that I've gone
across is 6 PI and so that's why I've
got you can see three copies basically
of the cosine graph now let's start by
saying cos x equals 1/2 again I've chose
a nice easy exact value for you what is
the angle that's the first solution it's
PI all right which if you have a look if
you've drawn a graph decently you should
be able to know okay my intercept is
pile up to 5 3 yeah cool
now from there I don't look at the fuss
around with anymore quadrants or
anything like that I'm just gonna look
at the graph and go from there
what's the nearest solution to pylon 3
the nearest one
the nearest one is the is the reflection
right now the reason why of course is
because cosine has what kind of symmetry
well it's even safe pi/3 is a solution
then maybe this kind of purity
you better believe it's also a solution
right so you can see what's happening
here on either side of zero X equal zero
I should say I've got a pair of
solutions now what happens when you have
a look at these two guys will have
includes so many copies of the done I
hope you can see that these two
solutions can get to these two solutions
taking advantage of the same trick we
used over here just with a different
number the period he was if the period
he was high rate unless that's why my PI
radians PI radians PI radians but the
period here is two pi radians is just
mentioned some of them take both of
these dimes and just go forward two pi
radians does that make sense
so you can see here I will do this point
because it was in case
two pi is six PI on three so therefore
this will be 7 PI and this guy over here
again I'm an 80-ton three takeaway
Planet three so that's five
or point remember I said to you hey look
this is zero and then you go forwards
and backwards and then there's appear
once this point here to PI right as even
six PI over three of what's the average
of these two fractions so there's two pi
of questions because I got to these
solutions by taking these two and moving
forward how far adds up to hi okay well
I can go to get another pair of
solutions in exactly the same way this
for black right if I go forwards I'm
going to get one nice a ninety six five
three right so to speak like a 13-mile I
did the moment walk is in the other one
which is this guy which is a landmine
take that value there so what's
happening here geometrically something
very similar they went but the
periodicity but there's some crucial
differences okay firstly I can say it
doesn't happen every PI radians of
course it doesn't because the period is
different
so therefore run say n PI which captures
0 PI 1 PI 2 pi 3 PI 4 PI I only want the
even ones only 1 0 pi 2 pi 4 PI o guess
I won 6 by 8 planets on so said it right
again PI I'm gonna write 2 2 n PI that
will give me all all the even ones right
and then for those even sports
I have to go forwards I also have to go
backwards I'm good I'm good do both
right because what I'm trying to do is
capture every single solution out there
not just one or two but a lot of them so
I want to go forwards and I also want to
go backwards in this case it's pyro
through
oh okay so notice what's the matter
what's different
there's still this in business I should
say and is an integer for the same
reason that it was performed okay but
it's to Empire your empire not for some
arbitrary reason it's because cosine has
a different period as a longer view then
what's his possible answer them yes
because I love pet okay every time where
is he you're just getting 1 1 1 so then
for that was because x equals a hunk
right
what about but cos x equals anything
right if I said the can again get raised
controller box for cos x equals K I'm
gonna say X is equal to 2 and PI plus or
minus what
that's why these pilot three came from
pile three is cos inverse of uh huh
enjoy guys
now to also want to point out so far
I've chosen nice easy values that are
all positive suppose I went over here
and I said keep your stop for me 10 x
equals negative 1 it's there or Christ
could I get me to solve cos x equals
negative a heart
we lemma for builders still home we
still work yeah I think they will well
let's have a look at this case first
okay if I was solving tendency doesn't
agree 1 instead of going for entire
going forward pilot for I'm just gonna
go n PI backwards purple which is
exactly what tan inverse does right 10
inverse of negative 1 it has no right
range it's just gonna hand you negative
platform right so the solution be n pi
minus powerful in this case what would
happen what would be different
if I put a negative 1/2 instead of a
half what's the range of cause what's
the range the batsman realized oh it's
multiplied right
so when you say of customers over
negative 1/2
it's gonna look down here and what is
that that's gonna be to pile of three I
believe okay so what you're gonna have
is its unit pi plus or minus two pine
tree you're gonna go this way you're
still going to get a pair of solutions
yeah you're going to go this way and
you're still gonna get a pair of
solutions does that make sense